i have my favorite hey my favorite man
k2
compliments of alan tudyk and hal hickle
and i just heard that you are not coming
back to andor is that true i think
you're lie are you lying
i am coming back probably at some point
i was there at the first announcement
d23 and at that point the story hadn't
been
formalized yet so now that it has been
formalized even though i was announced
in the beginning
and every announcement that i saw had me
involved
i'm not involved currently i will be
involved
at some later date okay
so you always have to talk about star
wars in a very tricky way you know
cassian when
this comes from rogue one passion and k2
were already a partnership a pair
and he's sort of she created k2 so he's
kind of like his dad
i know some people with children that
i've never not known with children but
these are the early days before he had
the child
and we'll get to see what kind of crazy
individual he is before that child
maybe he had another child maybe he has
a different droid maybe he
tries to turn a different droid into his
friend and it goes horribly wrong
i don't know i love your pitches though
i was hoping it was going to be you know
kind of like a
starsky hutch you know series maybe a
tango and cash
and k2 always had a little matchstick in
his mouth
he'll be back at some point and i'll
look forward to it
are you talking about memes well you've
been a part of like pretty much
every major franchise with a huge fan of
like firefly frozen dc
star wars which role do you get asked
about
most firefly definitely yeah because
firefly was canceled after only 14
episodes and became you know a cult hit
so the fans of firefly are fans it
wasn't an
easy fandom to get into you had to
especially from the very beginning
you really had to work to know it so
those are the fans i talk to because
they're the ones who'll come up to me
usually
uh and say hey i'm a leaf on the wind
they'll give me some kind of quote from
the show or the movie
serenity and they're the most passionate
but it's that's not weird
i'll get some yars and gars from when i
did dodgeball i was the pirate so
people who yell pirate sounds at me it
seems like on the street
oh that's funny i just feel like if i
saw you like i love that movie i just i
don't know if i'd pull that one out
[Laughter]
it's just that i unless everybody hears
yours and gars and i'm just like that's
about me and everybody's like no
people just yell that all the time man
my son
told me you're an alien well you don't
have anything to worry about
i'm not an alien
thank you for coming over hey congrats
on the show i know it's been in the
works for kind of a while
i think you were at like comic-con new
york 2019 promoting it how does it feel
to finally be
at the gate at the show's premiere so
good uh
i i've never looked forward to the gate
before
such a gate this gate i've been looking
forward to we shot the pilot and then we
took some time before we shot the series
and then of course kovid uh
interrupted everyone's lives and we came
back
and finished shooting there was we had
just two weeks left but you know there
was that period and they were like i
hope we finish this thing you know
there's so many options on the table
maybe they'll just stop with those
amount of episodes but scifi really
liked the show and
we all came back once production started
in vancouver again
and we finished it and now it's actually
coming out
wednesdays at 10 which is a great time
there's just a lot of good things
yeah no i mean i feel like through covet
that we got a lot of those emails that
were like
this is canceled this is cancelled this
is cancelling us like i have that moment
of like oh my god
i really want the show to see the light
of day right that's right
oh that was awful i love anything that's
like anybody who's like a fish out of
water scenario
so what's your kind of elevator pitch
for the show and why people should tune
in
an alien comes to earth to destroy all
of humanity
but crashes and has to take on
a human form until he can find the
device
to finish his mission comma
he gets pulled into
the small town of patience colorado to
solve
a local murder hilarity ensues
i i don't know i feel like there's
another comment in there somewhere that
i missed
this is awesome a good mystery figuring
out what happened
like law and order i love that he kind
of gets sucked into law and order and
starts mimicking that in the first
episode
so if you had like uh you know huh this
old chestnut when an alien friend comes
to town
what's the show that you would show them
to be like this is
the quintessential show i would show
them peaky blinders
i don't know i would show them modern
family or something you know that seems
to be a very american depiction of
that's that's humans i would like him to
watch other shows though
i think golden girls would be a good one
maybe something fun like um
like colombo that would be great get him
into colombo then he'd be so
great at solving crime yeah like a peter
falk or
or a murderer she wrote so i could be
pulling some angela lansbury out here
and there
the old magnum pi run around in those
shorts that he used to wear
no one wants to see that with me you
have some great
guest stars i believe linda hamilton is
one of them and i
like cannot even be in her presence she
is too regal for me
um she's amazing do you have like any
dream
guest stars you want to come in the show
is nathan phillian showing up at any
point
we still have some cast that are going
to be surprises along the way for the
season
i work with anybody from uh firefly of
course
if i can just have any actors catherine
hahn is one of my favorite actors
she's just so very very good sarah snook
her and i did a movie a long time ago in
australia she's fantastic she's in that
so i'd love for her to do that so we
could
uh reunite and do something because
she's a very good actress and now
she's having a huge moment jesse
plemmons is one of my favorite actors
i'd love for him to come on board
there's got to be so many hey
cassidy let's start there and then we'll
go
you know we'll see what's up jason mama
come on why not
who even are you very vander spiegel
just a normal human